DP how would you describe Deadpool to in
one sentence caddywhompus thumb puzzle
our Gallardo not really a sentence a
Deadpool to was like the Canadian
version of couples retreat with slightly
less Malin Akerman more like sugar raise
every morning but with slightly more
mark McGrath how would you describe
cable oh you're talking about the
character not the actor playing him I
was born into war right into it people
think they understand pain but they have
no concept gosh where do I start
uh well he's the biological son of
Cyclops and Madeline Pryor Jean Grey's
clone and a half-brother to Rachel
summers and Nate gray
I don't know why those air quotes were
in there who's raised as the Afghani son
and a genetic template for strife and a
possible alternate time long hadn't been
transported as an infant in the future
and infected with the techno-organic
virus consumes his light body with okay
let's just go without what will surprise
people about this movie
well actually we revealed the first
movie was all a Ryan Gosling wet dream
he's very handsome
are there any dry Ryan Gosling dreams
come on this Peter guy he kind of came
out of nowhere he's on the poster
everything Peter
any powered want to tell us about you no
I don't have one I just saw the ad
you're in right his career has just
taken off you know when it came time for
reshoots he was hip deep in this new
paramount project and they wouldn't let
him grow as moustache back so watch for
the digitally creative facial hair it's
is very hard to animate a moustache on
the move but seriously I love Peter
this guy's done more for Dockers and
anyone since Davis loved the third
famous love will anybody even get that
Davis love the third that is a dated
reference